today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video so
unless you've avoided news of all kinds
for the last four or five days you
probably know that things in the United
States have gotten extremely intense on
top of a global hundred year pandemic
coronavirus where the United States has
been one of the worst hit countries
thanks in part to our failed federal
leadership we have seen the tragedy of
George Floyd being killed by police in
Minnesota set off a string of extreme
civil unrest and this includes examples
of just about everything you can imagine
both by protesters and by those who are
pretending to be protesters but actually
have nefarious intentions and by police
as well and meanwhile we are completely
lacking anything that would be called
leadership from the Oval Office with
Donald Trump doing everything from
calling for pro Trump protesters to
gather at the White House on Saturday
night which they didn't all the way to
tweeting about essentially release the
hounds talking about Secret Service's
vicious dogs that would be unleashed on
protesters who breached the fence at the
White House up to and including flying
to Florida and taking credit for a
SpaceX launch of a falcon 9 rocket
carrying two astronauts to the
International Space Station while
retweeting videos of himself talking
about all of it Saturday as protests
raged and buildings burned and I really
spent a lot of time this weekend
thinking about what's the primary story
here what's like the main analysis that
has to be done what's the lens through
which we need to understand what's
happening in our country right now
because I wanted to come to you and give
you that point of view here's really
what this is about
and the conclusion I came to is that
there is no one lens things are more
complicated then this is really what's
going on and I know that there are a ton
of hot takes about this if you look at
Twitter lately if you look at cable news
everybody claims to hold the real key
they claim to say this is the true
filter through which this should all be
seen I'm here to tell you I don't have
such a lens for you because I believe
any such lens is too simplistic now if
you want that simplistic analysis there
are plenty available there's no question
about it but to some degree we sometimes
are blinded by narrative and in some
cases if all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail meaning if
you want to see every issue as being
related to one problem you're able to
find a way to do that even if it's not
really the right or most robust analysis
so I'm gonna give you some examples and
then we'll get to what I think is a
reasonable analysis and way to think
about all of this so one story line
we're hearing and we've heard it from a
lot of different people is this is
merely about race this is about white
cops killing black people this is about
white cops oppressing black protesters
this is about a fundamentally racist
justice system it's about a fundamental
fundamentally racist society it's it
that's what the lens is now of course
rage race is a massive component that is
causing understandable rage among a lot
of people but that analysis doesn't tell
you everything that you need to know our
economic system at its core for example
functions to stymie and suppress real
change in activism and it goes way
beyond race has racial implications of
course but you miss that if you make
this only about race much of that
economic system is certainly rooted in
supremacy x' along racial lines but a
race only analysis falls short
a lot of the hotcakes we're seeing or
are only about race another perspective
that is
heavily represented it is that this is
really about capitalism right any
capitalist system is inevitably racist
and inevitably leads to this degree of
social unrest arson looting property
damage police violence against
protesters protesters islands against
police protests our own protest or
violence protesters versus looters that
the idea is that is because of a
capitalist system making this simply
about capitalism ignores the countless
social democracies right which that's a
form of capitalism is regulated
capitalism that are some of the places
where these issues of inequality and
racial tensions have been best dealt
with around the world some of the best
examples in fact of functioning
societies with reduced income inequality
reduced racial inequality social safety
nets trust in institutions less
corruption they are regulated versions
of capitalism so I believe that the
capitalism analysis also fails another
lens that's being presented as the lens
is simply about police brutality meaning
this is about police brutality
as what killed George Floyd this is
about police brutality as the problem in
the protests in other words if it
weren't for police brutality George
Floyd would be alive if George Floyd
were alive we wouldn't be seeing these
protests we at the protests are also
just seeing further police brutality now
there is no shortage of police brutality
at the protests what happened the George
Floyd is unconscionable but this is
about so much more than that including
economic and racial issues it's about
the militarization of law enforcement in
the United States and there are people
making it only about that it's not only
about that but that's that's a part of
it when you militarized law enforcement
you create overly aggressive policing
you can argue that that played a role in
George Floyd's death militarization is
what led police in riot gear in dozens
of cities over the weekend to use tear
gas and rubber bullets and to see media
and random bystanders and
even people peacefully protesting which
is of course their right to do horribly
injured by police
so militarization of law enforcement is
another huge problem in the u.s. we've
covered it but it is not the only lens
that we need to be using so here's the
reality when you think about this and we
often want things to be black and white
we want to say this is what this is
really about the reality is this is a
country of 331 million people we have
examples of everything you can imagine
we have dozens of different problems
that relate to what we are now seeing
just this weekend we saw sickening
violence done by police to protesters
including for example an elderly man
with a cane shoved onto the ground by
police and we saw police and I believe
it was Michigan show up and tell the
protesters I'm putting down my weapons
I'm with you let's march together we saw
protesters burn entire buildings and
brutalize business owners including
middle-aged women and yet we also saw
protesters guard a police officer who
was separated from his squad on Saturday
night and this is the risk about the out
of context sharing of pictures and video
on social media 10 seconds from one
protest and 15 from another and and I
actually did some of this over the
weekend and I don't know that it was the
best thing not only does it lack
immediate context it lacks broader
context about all of the issues that
have gotten us to where we are now
including by the way a complete lack of
leadership from the president and we're
going to talk about that later which is
why I'm not digging into it too much
right here so my message is what we are
seeing is mostly about systems and it is
less about individuals you're seeing a
ton of debates about what portion of
police are good versus bad which is very
fraught terminology anyway good good and
bad what portion of protesters have good
or bad intentions what portion of
protesters are grassroots members of the
community versus out-of-town astroturf
furs as has been a growing narrative
over the weekend used in part to
discredit the real and justified anger
that protesters have about what's
in their communities the problem is if
you just argue about that if you spend
your time on those questions
well 82% of the protesters are good or
whatever you might say you're not really
digging into the systemic elements at
play if we figure out it's 85 percent of
the protesters that are good instead of
80 then what it's good fodder for
corporate media it does little for
anybody else
so I don't pretend to have one single
unifying theory about this this is what
it's really about and at the exclusion
of other things that's not something
you're going to hear from me but what I
can tell you for sure is that you won't
understand any of this if you don't
understand the context and that's where
a lot of the local news coverage of the
protests has failed which is a complete
lack of context Oh somebody looted a
Cheesecake Factory and they came out
with the cheesecake that's coverage that
we saw doesn't really tell us anything
about what's going on
so racialized policing combined with a
two-tiered justice system for rich and
poor a system that focuses on street
crime at the exclusion of white-collar
crime combined with an economic system
that doesn't work for a huge portion of
the country in addition to right now
having nearly 25% unofficial
unemployment in the midst of a hundred
year pandemic in addition to a complete
absence of federal leadership from a
president who tweeted all weekend from
his bunker at the White House combined
with corporate media that really is
seeking to foment division rather than
find solutions doesn't it's not a good
recipe and then you add to that
militarized law enforcement that seems
to always have money despite we
supposedly lacking more suppose that
lack of money for health care and
education it's all of that stuff
together now I want to be really clear
this is not like a social justice
intersectionality analysis of race and
gender and relates it's not that what it
is is an understanding that we have
systems in our country that are bigger
than any one protest or any one police
officer and only with that multi focused
perspective can you really get anything
that we would call an all-encompassing
analysis let me give
you another example of a false debate
riots are good versus riots are bad or
riots are effective versus the riots are
ineffective or they are criminal or they
are heroic first of all a ton of this
debate is actually semantics in terms of
some people are arguing over whether
riots are good or bad
others are arguing over what counts as a
riot versus a protest
there's racialization of the language
there's a lack of context etc but what
you really have to understand is you can
simultaneously say I'm against violence
both against people and property I
believe is it is unlikely that the
violence will achieve much and yet at
the same time I understand that people
have had it and I get what's going on
right someone's a son is killed by
police and then a window gets smashed
it's hard to feel like these things are
equivalent in any way without needing to
endorse property damage we can
understand that people have absolutely
had it people are sick and tired of the
status quo and while I might not think
we will achieve change by breaking
windows I understand and sympathize with
the absolute anger and disgust with
these systems that protesters have now I
have to tell you the argument that the
unrest has accomplished nothing I don't
know if it's a good argument you all
know that I have always said I favor
legal protests I'm against violence and
get including against most forms of
property crime over the weekend we saw
the officer who killed George Floyd
Derek shavon arrested we saw Fox News
Sunday devote an hour to the protests to
George Floyd and to how coronavirus
disproportionately affects communities
of color with guest Cornel West I don't
know that were it not for the national
unrest we would have seen that be the
Fox News Sunday show I don't know I I
think that what's what we're seeing
played a role in what Fox News even
decided to do on Sunday would we have
seen Derek shavon get arrested would we
potentially be
the other three officers get arrested
were it not for this degree of unrest I
don't know is the question it's less
clear to me that this has accomplished
nothing and that is separate from
whether these are tactics that I condone
last thing and I want to be really clear
here this is not like some kumbaya
segment where everyone's thoughts are
equally valid and everyone is equally
responsible for what's going on that's
not what this is but what we need to
understand is that the word privilege is
often thrown around you're privileged if
you say cops are mostly good and protect
you because a lot of people live in
places where the cops aren't primarily
there to protect you or at least it
certainly doesn't feel that way if
you're part of certain communities or
you're privileged to be against property
crime during protests because you lived
somewhere safe and the systems work for
you and you can't possibly imagine what
it's like to actually be in the position
that a lot of the protesters are in in
some way all of those allegations are
correct and yet this is not so much
about individual privilege it's again
systems that aren't working for large
swaths of people and that gets me to my
last thought in history we've seen
unrest lead to movements which lead to
activism which will often enter the
political and legal space which at some
point will end up being decided by a
judge somewhere look at Brown v Board of
Education the landmark is a decision
that said states can't segregate schools
by race that was in 1954 it started in
1951 in Kansas it involved three years
of activism protests consensus-building
and eventually it was a Supreme Court
decision under Earl Warren that decided
nine to zero on the court schools can't
racially segregated to happen next do
not miss the forest for the trees that
may come one two or three years down the
line if what is going on now will lead
to change it may come down to who is on
the Supreme Court in one two or three
years I don't even have to tell you what
that means about a decision we all have
to make five months from now because you
all know exact
what that decision is so two weeks ago I
did a story asking is the United States
a failed state we failed on a medical
response to the pandemic
health systems falling apart corruption
no trust in government are we a failed
state we are now finding ourselves
asking is the u.s. first world country
in light of the completely absent
leadership as federal from federal
government as protests raged nationally
over out-of-control policing as it is
seen by millions and millions of people
and in addition to the protests literal
dumpster fires around the White House as
the White House sits in darkness with
Trump tweeting as you have violence
police attacking protesters protesters
attacking police we're seeing media get
shot with rubber bullets and attacked
not just physically but ideologically
for their presence at the unrest Caitlyn
rust a reporter for an NBC affiliate
station in Louisville Kentucky was fired
upon by police Friday night covering a
live street protest that was going on
CNN reporter Omar Jimenez was arrested
while covering protests over the weekend
subsequently released it was chalked up
to confusion by police about who he was
he happens to be black last night
Cleveland Police said no media would be
allowed in any of the downtown area as
protests raged it's not even clear that
that's legal to do this concept of a
first world country comes from the Cold
War it has some implicit biases but
really now what we're talking about is
the westernized developed nations of the
world so look at what we have corrupt
incompetent leadership increasing
attacks on media by government and by
police growing unrest between police and
the public a judiciary system that has
two tiers one for the rich and one for
the poor we've got rampant cronyism and
corruption lack of access to quality
health care for a huge portion of the
country a failing education system our
response to the corona virus pandemic
has completely failed compared to other
developed nations infrastructure is not
crumbling but we are way behind where we
should be for a country of
our wealth look at our airports to some
around the world look at our highways to
those in many parts of the world and
meanwhile our president is sitting in a
white and a darkened White House
sometimes in the bunker below it on
Friday night as DC literally burns
providing no leadership no words of
de-escalation nothing other than self
aggrandizement and threats to protesters
so I'm not literally saying we are no
longer a first world country but more
and more we're reacting to events the
way a less advanced country would I want
to hear from you about this I will have
more about it upcoming let me know your
thoughts on Twitter at D Pakman remember
to make sure you are subscribed for free
through the daily one hour-long David
Pakman show podcast on whatever
podcasting app you use the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink as' to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman i've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Tom Cunningham and Chad Sampson
thanks so much to both of you guys also
want to say thanks to Kelly good Kelly
is today's longtime sustaining member of
the day she's been a member for almost
five years
grab a membership get all the great
membership benefits including the daily
bonus show by signing up at join
pakman.com there are images of police
using violence against peaceful
protesters there are images of police
creating confrontations even attacking
but defenseless elderly people we played
a video of police knocking over an
elderly man with a cane shooting at the
media these images have gone viral over
the weekend now I want to be really
clear I already did a story about how
what's going on in America right now is
not just about one thing it's not just
about race it's not only about police
it's not exclusively about capitalism or
Trump this is a massive multifaceted
ordeal but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't look at individual elements
and one of these elements is the idea of
police as oppressors versus police's
victims as some have started framing
police to be we are seeing wholesale
pepper spraying of peaceful protesters
we've seen members of the media shot
with rubber bullets we saw kids hit with
pepper spray we've seen police ramming
police vehicles into crowds a Dallas
woman was hit in the face with a rubber
bullet while walking home with her
groceries police wildly hitting people
with batons in some cases people walking
away from protests
none of this excuses any violent actions
by protesters and there have been
horrible actions including attacking
business owners beating one business
owner to within an inch of his life for
trying to defend his business beating a
female business owner brutally out in
front of her store we have seen it all
but I want to focus in a little bit here
on the police component and talk about
it with you there are people and I'm
friends with some of them on
I'm seeing it on Twitter there are
people who have immediately taken to
painting police's victims arguments like
a bad cop may have killed George Floyd
in Minnesota but now innocent police all
over the place are being attacked for no
reason and often these arguments end up
in debates about numbers like well most
police are good
who is it 97% or 99% well is it 99 or
99.3% and I said earlier in the show
imagine we figured out with some
precision what portion of police are the
problem is we might call it and what
portion of police are not imagine ninety
nine point two percent of police are
good okay well I imagine that most of my
audience even if you're okay with
property crime in protests where
insurance companies are the ones taking
a hit and corporations I imagine most of
my audience is not okay with unprovoked
attacks against random police officers
who aren't doing anything wrong if you
do believe that for what happened to
George Floyd in Minnesota it's okay to
just physically attack an officer in
Miami we're just not on the same page I
think that's the minority of my audience
does our analysis depend though on
whether it's ninety nine point two or
ninety nine point three percent of
police that are good guys in it for the
right reasons because what really this
is about is context and power dynamics
in total once you concede that most cops
are good and doing their job as best
they can often in difficult situations
sometimes dangerous situations you also
have some cops that go into law
enforcement specifically because they
would love an opportunity to beat the
crap out of someone just like some
portion of people go into the military
because they like the idea of shooting
someone and killing them in some kind of
theater of war at some point that is
some percentage okay so so then what
right
whether it's 0.8 or 0.7 or 0.08 percent
of police that are going in because they
want to do violence and misbehave and
have all the worst intentions what next
and that's where the more difficult
conversations start questions like are
the good cops who are just
doing their job part of the problem in
that if you're not part of the solution
are you implicitly supporting the status
quo of that small percentage of police
that do horrible things and get away
with it
to what degree should every quote good
cop quit in protest to show solidarity
with the protests leaving our country to
be policed only by the bad cops what
counts as a sign of being complicit is
silence a sign of being complicit
what power and responsibility do
individual police officers have to fix
the problem versus police chiefs versus
federal law enforcement agencies versus
versus police unions that represent
officers around the country should the
good cops be treated respectfully or
suspiciously absent any reason to
believe they are one of the bad cops how
should they be treated by protesters the
average person etc when you start asking
these questions you realize that most of
the changes that need to be made are
systemic changes it needs to be much
more likely that if you do the wrong
thing as a police officer you will be
caught and punished it's not likely
right now in a lot of our society just
from this weekend we have dozens if not
hundreds of officers on video doing
horrible things are we confident they're
going to be identified and investigated
and charged and punished when it's
appropriate not really because if it
were more likely that they were held
accountable they would probably change
their behavior that is a systemic issue
a good system will take care of that
sliver of police that are doing SiC
horrible things so let's answer the
questions one by one first of all being
a police officer is not like being an
accountant okay
accountants don't represent communities
in the way that police officers do
accountants don't wield their power with
firearms and accountants don't have a
power dynamic relative to their clients
the way police officers have a power
dynamic relative to the people that they
are dealing with so on the one hand the
good police officers must say much more
Lao
these things are not okay and we're
committed to fixing it and changing it
and good for them many police officers
have done exactly that at the same time
the anger by protesters towards a system
of policing that is fundamentally broken
in many parts of our country is
justified anger and this is why it's so
powerful when police officers get it and
say I'm with you like the sheriff in
Michigan who marched with protesters and
the video going viral and it's important
for protesters to know that their anger
with the system is justified and yet
it's not okay to go attack random
individual cops who have not done
anything wrong which is why it was great
to see protesters protecting a police
officer Saturday night who had done
nothing wrong and was separated from his
squad this is why it was great to see
video from I believe it was Brooklyn
last night with organizers saying do not
interact with the police we are not here
for that we are here to get our message
out do not incite violence if you see
anyone inciting violence call them out
and you know in the midst of this
there's this really ugly thing that's
going on where there are people sort of
making the focus that the protesters are
from out of town and at one point there
was some wrong report that more than
half of protesters in some place were
from out of town
another report it said it seemed like
one out of seven were from out of town
now sometimes that could mean the next
town over it's not really a big deal but
the point is this out of town narrative
is being used to imply that you merely
have people from other communities who
are not coming in to protest because
they actually are concerned about police
brutality and relations or whatever but
that they are coming in to provoke or to
loot or to steal you could be concerned
about what went on and drive from
another state and it also appears to be
completely untrue so we've got to be
really understanding of how some of
these narratives are being used to
distort and discredit real justifiable
anger we also have to recognize the
growing number of
that are saying we are not here to do
violence at all and we are not here to
do violence to the police but we have to
realize that the anger is justified
given the systemic dynamics that exist
that's sort of my sense of it right now
I'm glad to hear from you about it as
well okay so now let's go from talking
about police to talking about
destruction of property there are
reasonable people who have centered in
on what seems to be a dividing line as
we see unrest and protests and physical
violence and property damage around the
country when we talk about property
damage there is often a debate as to
whether it counts as violence in the
sense of when people say I am against
violence
so most people agree attacking random
bystanders who aren't being violent is
unacceptable violence attacking random
police who aren't doing anything wrong
that is violence in the in any sense of
the word
most people agree blocking traffic is
not violence now you could be for or
against blocking traffic as a protest
tactic but most people would not say
blocking traffic is violence you could
maybe say well if you prevent people
from getting to work and then they lose
their jobs blocking traffic becomes kind
of like economic violence but in the
kind of violence we're talking about
blocking traffic
most people agree is is not violence
what about property damage so first of
all we have to call out the right-wing
hypocrites on this issue the concern
trolls who a month ago we're saying
sacrifice grandma to coronavirus in
order to open the economy who are now
saying the worst thing you can do is
break the windows of a big-box store
they are hypocrites I'm not interested
in those hypocritical concern trolls I
want to deal with the real people with
the sensible people who in a real way
want to talk about this there are folks
who believe that for example destroying
government property when no one gets
physically hurt is okay but for example
destroying a private business is not
okay that depends on who you're
targeting you could be targeting a
business with bad practices or you could
be targeting a government that is a bad
actor
whatever you could find you know a
logging company and say we are going to
destroy or disable their bulldozers so
that they cannot take down these trees
saying what determines whether
destruction of property is violence is
merely whether you're doing it to a
government property or to private
property I don't think that's really the
dividing line what this comes down to is
what do we mean by violence violence
defined as behavior involving physical
force to hurt damage or kill someone or
something damaging property sort of fits
if you want to take a legal perspective
certainly the unlawful exercise of force
or the exhibition of such force would
encompass the destruction of property
now others would say the real crux of
human violence versus physical violence
against people rather than objects is
where we should be focusing if you are
talking about breaking a window that's
not really what a lot of people believe
is violence so here's the bottom line if
you want to make this a semantic
argument if you want to make this about
definitions you can define violence in a
way that does or doesn't include
property crime it won't really get to
the underlying issue and the underlying
issue is whether sometimes violence is
justified so even if we agree on whether
property crime is or is not violence
that doesn't answer the question of
whether property crime destruction of
property is a valid form of protest who
gets to decide what's in the protesting
playbook if you leave the protesting
playbook only to the elites and those in
positions of power it will be restricted
to only writing letters you know
chanting and holding sign right the
point is if you let those already in
power define what is okay in terms of
protesting certainly nothing will ever
change now is there any guarantee that
destroying property is going to achieve
change there's not we do know that
destruction of property has been a part
of protesting for a really long time you
look at the Boston Tea Party
property to fight back against the
capitalist monopolies and political
rights that were being claimed by
British colonists you look at slave
uprisings in the United States which
included destruction of property you
look at the plowshares aid a group of
eight Christians including priests and
nuns who took hammers to the nose cones
of some nuclear warheads poured their
blood on the facilities papers and a
call for peace
so the legality part of it is clear this
stuff is illegal to do but I think we
can all every single one of us imagine a
situation where we do the moderate
methods and they bring no change they
don't get attention and then you say
well we don't want to do violence to
people but we're going to start
destroying some property destruction of
property in my mind is clearly violence
of a kind but in certain situations it
might be the only thing people have left
short of starting to actually do
violence to individuals now which
situations count I don't know I don't
know what about the consequences well
there are consequences you're not going
to get around that will property damage
get you what you want often it will not
property damage may in fact do the
opposite it may turn public opinion
against you but whether property damage
that's not hurting anyone physically is
a valid form of protest that's a
question that goes back at least
hundreds of years and anybody pretending
that there is one single solitary answer
that applies to every situation is just
wrong history tells us that's not the
case I want to hear from you about this
we're going to continue covering it on
the david packard show instagram at
david patten show we will take a break
and be back with much more the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show we are
currently in a crisis of leadership so
severe in the United States that Donald
Trump spent his weekend retweeting
videos of himself and threatening
protestors with vicious dogs and
violence from Secret Service agents
rather than leading uniting doing
something productive because he doesn't
know how to do those things and
according to one White House report the
reason we've not heard from Donald Trump
something from the Oval Office a message
of unity is that Trump has nothing to
say
so rather he's staying quiet except not
really because he's tweeting
uncontrollably the u.s. is devolving
into chaos
Trump spent the weekend retweeting
videos of himself trying to take credit
for the SpaceX launch threatening
protesters with vicious dogs claiming
he'll designate antifa a terrorist
organization he has no idea what to do
it is a complete lack of leadership we
fortunately heard from former President
Barack Obama with something that could
be approximating leadership we're going
to look at a couple of items here
starting with Donald Trump's threats to
unleash vicious dogs on protesters he
might as well have said we're gonna get
the fire hoses out as well there have
been varying levels of unrest around the
country stemming from the police killing
of George Floyd this includes people
near the White House Trump tweeted on
Saturday about protesters near the White
House
check this out this incredibly ludicrous
rant Trump saying quote great job
tonight at the White House by the US
Secret Service they were not only
totally professional but very cool I was
inside watched every move and couldn't
have felt more safe and they let the
protesters scream and rant as much as
they wanted but whenever someone got too
frisky or out of line they would quickly
come down on them hard didn't know what
hit him
the front line was replaced with fresh
agents like magic big crowd
professionally organized but nobody came
close to breaching the fence if they had
they would have been greeted with the
most vicious dogs and ominous weapons I
have ever seen that's when people would
have been really badly hurt at least
many Secret Service agents just waiting
for action we put the young ones on the
front line sir and they loved it he
might as well be saying Secret Service
is thirsty for blood and we're bringing
out the fire hoses release the hounds is
what he is essentially saying here now
this point about you know vicious dogs
and ominous weapons that that's bad
enough the idea that young Secret
Service agents are just waiting for
action that's Trump admitting claiming
I'm guessing the Secret Service would
would not even agree with Trump's
characterization this is Trump claiming
that Secret Service is looking to beat
the crap out of people that's the
opposite of leadership that's the
opposite of bringing calm to a nation
that is dealing with essentially the the
Spanish flu at the same time as some of
the worst civil unrest that we have seen
in addition to a complete lack of
federal leadership all combined at the
same time with a recession slash
depression going on it's all happening
at once and Trump is doing nothing to
actually bring people together a real
leader would ask for calm a real leader
would go to the Oval Office and address
the nation saying we are a nation in
struggle I hear you I hear your concerns
and your complaints I'm committed to
working together to improve the country
let's stop the violence let's stop the
attack stop the violence by police let's
realize that we are one nation currently
fighting a pandemic and a
depression no one benefits from adding
this chaos to the pandemic I'm here with
you on the inequality in our justice
system
I'm here with you on policing give me
the space and the calm I need to work on
this instead he tweets threats about
vicious dogs retweets himself taking
credit for the rocket launch over the
weekend that has nothing to do with him
says hey aunty Fay you're now a
terrorist organization which I will get
to next
this is incompetence combined with
authoritarianism from a wannabe dictator
Donald Trump don't for a second think
that Donald Trump by the way is not deep
down planning to use these protests to
further disrupt the twenty20 election
for his benefit unrest in major cities
things are way too crazy for
vote-by-mail ballots will be stolen or
something
we absolutely can't do it Trump has the
power of the bully pulpit at any point
he could say I'm gonna use that for good
he could do it now in so many ways the
country is plagued by challenges the
pandemic financial crisis oppression
discrimination coming to a head and we
have nothing from Trump he also tweeted
when the looting starts the shooting
starts that's a quote from violent
racist Miami police chief I forget his
name years ago a tweet so hideous it was
flagged by Twitter as glorifying
violence a real leader would dial down
the anger and the heat Trump doesn't
know how to do that so he's antagonizing
protesters he's riling up his own base
he's firing up the gun people and he's
not even pretending to represent all
Americans here Trump opens his mouth and
trash falls out that shouldn't surprise
us anymore
I hope people are realizing the urgent
urgent nature of removing this president
and we've got to keep our eye on the
ball because the distractions keep
coming and that's what I want to talk
about next
we cannot be distracted by Donald
Trump's antics from the real crises and
real responsibilities and duties that we
have the virus police killings protests
evolving into chaos and violence
removing Trump must be done
but Trump is very aggressively trying to
distract us I already told you some of
the ways earlier and the latest is Trump
tweeting that he will be designating an
Tifa as a terrorist organization Donald
Trump of course announcing this on
Twitter saying quote the United States
of America will be designated a
designating an Tifa as the terrorist
organization there's a few different
things to talk about here auntie feh is
a militant left-wing movement that
stands for anti-fascism
and Tifa okay that's where the name
comes from an Tifa is not centrally
organized it's a sort of umbrella
designation and Tifa I see is more of a
strategy than a group of people per se
and sometimes they do violent things
that I vehemently oppose I have been
endlessly critical of many of the
tactics employed by individuals
organizing under the umbrella of anti
feh it appears though that what Donald
Trump is trying to do here is not
actually constitutional in designating
them a terrorist organization the United
States State Department has a list of
terrorist organizations they are foreign
Auntie feh is not foreign auntie feh is
a domestic group even more importantly
if Donald Trump were to designate antifa
as a terrorist organization they would
lose some First Amendment protections
which apply only to foreign terrorist
organizations so understand that this is
part of the framing by Trump and William
bar that the recent protests and unrest
are merely left-wing anarchists looking
to do violence and so chaos now to be
clear there is no shortage of anarchists
all over the political spectrum doing
protesting many with ulterior motives
but there is also plenty of right-wing
astroturf there is police escalation by
way of haphazard pepper spraying
shooting at media etc and this entire
story of this is not genuine anger and
frustration with policing in America or
whatever else these are provocateur
is coming in from outside that is being
used to single-handedly devalue the
complaints and concerns that the
protesters have and we can't fall for
that but this claim from Donald Trump
that he will be designating and Tifa as
a terrorist organization it's a
political statement it is not a law
enforcement statement it's really
important to understand that and it
doesn't appear to be a legal statement
either Trump really cannot designate a
domestic group a terrorist organization
it would deny them their First Amendment
rights it would also deny them due
process and it is likely
unconstitutional and it's not something
Trump is going to be able to do he may
not even really try because understand
the State Department's list of foreign
terrorist organization you just can't
put aunty Fay on that list but he set it
on Twitter and that's the whole point
that's the big picture here this is
another attempt to distract we must keep
our eyes on the ball
Trump has failed on coronavirus more
than a hundred and five thousand have
died 50 or 60% of those deaths those
deaths could have been prevented by a
two-week earlier request from Trump for
a 50-state stay at home order an actual
testing capacity on that note I don't
want to get you to something boring but
understand
Trump's tweeting about designating an
Tifa a terrorist organization we still
after four months aren't testing five
hundred thousand people a day in the
United States we still after four months
aren't at the absolute minimum testing
we need to really look at reopening the
country we have national unrest with
protests violence looting destruction of
property arson Trump's tweeting about an
tyfa and that the White House will
release vicious dogs to go after
protesters if they get past the fence oh
and by the way the wall isn't being
built Trump didn't repeal and replace
Obamacare with something better like he
said he would his trade war with China
has failed 25% of the workforce is out
of jobs in the last ten weeks
so of course Donald Trump is time trying
to take credit for SpaceX and make this
about an Tifa and otherwise pretend that
he's doing a great job it is an abject
failure that we have not seen in the
United States for a long time and you
have you have to look at Bush's failure
on 9/11 when he said let's go into Iraq
even though
they didn't have anything to do with the
9/11 attacks and this is all meant to
distract it actually is starting to feel
like it may not work if you look at
polling cautious optimism that what
Trump is doing to distract isn't working
assume nothing every one of us has to
vote in November the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so over the last 48 hours we've had a
stunning contrast between the man who is
currently president of the United States
and the man that wants to be President
of the United States and I'm talking of
course of and Joe Biden Donald Trump as
I've already told you to some degree a
sat in the White House at one point in
the basement bunker at another point he
went down to Florida to give a speech
about Elon Musk's success with NASA in
launching the Falcon 9 rocket with the
dragon spacecraft to bring two
astronauts to the space station and
Donald Trump essentially spent the
weekend tweeting attacking the motives
of protesters threatening to release
vicious dogs against protesters and
generally escalating tensions meanwhile
Joe Biden who is four years Trumps
senior went out and wearing a mask
talked to actual protesters about what's
going on why they are protesting and all
of these relevant issues in society
today took pictures with people while
tweeting conciliatory and understanding
things rather than threatening people
with releasing the hounds essentially
the the contrast could not be more stark
at this point no national address from
Trump meant to reduce tensions and bring
people together instead a weekend of
tweets about vicious dogs an ominous
weapons and the Secret Service is going
to go after people tweets talking about
we're gonna make an Tifa a terrorist
organization and then Trump being rushed
on Friday to the underground bunker used
to protect presidents during terrorist
attacks below the White House even China
goading from foreign ministry spokesman
lesion Zhao urged the United States to
eliminate racial discrimination and
protect the lawful rights of minorities
huija jean editor of the nationalist
tabloid Global Times telling Donald
Trump mr. president don't go hide behind
The Secret Service now that's Trump then
you have Biden Biden who you don't have
to like you don't
to see is a progressive because he's not
Joe Biden went and met with protesters
tweeted conciliatory messages you don't
have to love Biden to understand the
difference between these two men you
don't have to see Biden as a progressive
because as I said he's not to realize
that the world is laughing at us and we
would be better off if they stopped and
replacing Donald Trump with Biden is the
option we have five months from now and
I will be doing everything I can to make
sure that that replacement takes place
Trump tweeting about releasing the
hounds on protesters Joe Biden tweeting
quote we are a nation in pain right now
but we must not allow this pain to
destroy us as president I will help lead
this conversation and more importantly I
will listen just as I did today visiting
the site of last night's protest in
Wilmington Biden publishing a five
minute video discussing what we are
seeing with police and George Floyd in
some detail adding quote we are a
country with an open wound none of us
can turn away none of us can be silent
none of us any longer can hear those
words I can't breathe and do nothing we
must commit as a nation to pursue
justice with every ounce of our being
and most importantly maybe Joe Biden not
hanging out and about and a bunker or in
his basement in Delaware but just going
out and talking to protesters were
showing some of that video now so listen
am I saying Joe Biden is the be-all
end-all on criminal justice reform of
course not Joe Biden sponsored the 1994
crime bill that was so destructive
Bernie Sanders also voted for it by the
way and there is no doubt that not
enough was done during Barack Obama's
administration of which Biden was a part
on criminal justice but this is
comparing apples to bicycles it's
comparing apples to trash when it comes
to Biden and Trump and the leadership
deficit that we're experiencing right
now it's a tragedy and the optics of
Trump tweeting from a White House bunker
while Joe Biden is kneeling with
protesters this isn't good for Trump it
shouldn't be good for Trump
Biden of course would not get everything
right as president but at least he would
bring back something that looks and
feels like leadership and like a man
connected to what's happening in the
country rather than a guy who will
literally sit in his basement tweeting
ajik trash as more and more violence is
instigated by virtue of his every tweet
speaking of a furious basement-dwelling
Trump this is fascinating and hilarious
Donald Trump has been completely
embarrassed by world leaders including
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel who
turned down Trump's invitation to come
to the US for the g7 summit at the White
House so understand the backstory for a
few weeks now the White House has
continued to talk about we want to do
the g7 we might do it at Camp David we
might do it at the White House
coronavirus no I think we're gonna be
able to do it it's gonna be really
really great and reporters smartly were
asking should you be doing this given
the pandemic but also which world
leaders have accepted your invitation so
far and they didn't say but they just
kept insisting Trump did in Keighley
mcenany world leaders are reacting very
favorably we're gonna have news about
this soon yada-yada hopefully it'll
happen at the end of June everything's
gonna be fine
we suspected this was BS most world
leaders clearly from what they say
understand this is not the time to be
traveling all over the world possibly
spreading coronavirus to come and give
Trump his photo op at the White House or
Camp David and one of the first to turn
down the invitation over the weekend was
German Chancellor Angela Merkel who
essentially said no thanks she said I'm
not going it's too early to reopen we
shouldn't be having large gatherings the
virus is very much circulating and Trump
reportedly furious at Angela Merkel and
then Trump does this thing that you know
it's not surprising but it's so pathetic
Trump decides to pretend it was really
his decision not to do the g7 and that
the countries that are currently in it
aren't really the right ones calls it an
outdated group and according to press
pool reports Donald Trump said
I'm postponing it because I don't feel
as a g7 it probably represents what's
going on in the world it's a very
outdated group Trump mentioning that he
wants to add Russia and some other
countries to the group so this is an
obvious lie Trump is postponing it
because nobody's coming they've turned
down the invitation at least on gula
Merkel has world leaders said no and now
Trump is pretending he didn't want it to
happen with this group anyway and the
entire you know adding Russia thing and
the group being outdated this is how
Trump attacks people that don't want to
say yes to him quite simply it's just
everything is a childish temper tantrum
now just imagine what Trump will do if
he loses in November it will be like
nothing we have seen before from any
president one other sort of interesting
thing about the whole g7 Fiasco this is
why diplomats exist in a normal
administration you don't have Trump for
a month saying we're gonna push for g7
and every leaders are reacting very
positively very strong positive
reactions in a normal situation
diplomats figure all of this out you
don't put Trump out there on a limb
saying we're doing the g7 and we're
doing it here even though they're not
actually yet scheduled to do it then you
end up with world leaders saying no
thanks and Trump tries to save face by
saying well I want better countries in
it anyway in a normal administration
diplomats handle this there will be one
statement about it and it is either we
have decided to postpone the g7 due to
coronavirus fears or we are confirmed
having the g7 on such and such date you
avoid all of these embarrassing Fiasco's
in the first place this is all self harm
done by Donald Trump and the degree to
which he is being shunned by world
leaders is really representative of just
a slide down the totem pole so to speak
for the US presidency globally it's
embarrassing to Americans it needs to
change and just imagine this is what
Trump is doing over uncle Merkel saying
no thanks just imagine what he will do
if he is indeed defeated in November we
have a voicemail number good question in
this boy
smell that number is two one nine two
david p voicemail caller says hey
there's a lot of crazy stuff going on
but like is any more money coming for
coronavirus because it's been four
months and we got 1,200 bucks hey David
I was just really curious especially
with the end of the month coming up
we've only gotten one stimulus package
or direct payment to the to the people
yep wondering if you offhand knew what
percentage of this stimulus package I
mean everything including going to the
banks and all the the cruise liners all
these different companies yeah what
percentage of all of that went directly
to the people how much of our tax money
was dished out to companies compared to
how much did we get our money yeah so a
couple of things there I mean first of
all I believe that we had a sick I
thought it was six trillion total and
that two trillion was direct stimulus
and then a bunch went to specific big
industries and then a bunch was
available to smaller and big businesses
through PPP I don't have those exact
numbers and then the bigger question is
this started in mid-march for a lot of
people we are now in June for some
people this sort of started to ramp up
in February and places that took it
really seriously earlier is $1,200 gonna
be it or is there going to be some more
stimulus coming the second quarter
numbers
second quarter being April May June
we're now in the third of three months
of the second quarter if we don't start
seeing recovery there has to be more
something more is going to have to be
done and I mean you've got people like
Roe kana with proposals you have other
members of Congress with proposals
Trump's not talking about it is it this
just doesn't work 1200 bucks and
unemployment only for people who
completely lost their jobs it's just not
going to cut it and one of the things we
will be talking about on the bonus show
today is that a lot of the eviction
freezes are expiring now it's June first
some eviction freezes expire and people
aren't going to have money for the rent
that's due today June 1st so we'll talk
about that on the bonus show we will
also talk about much more get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member
at join pakman.com it takes seconds and
remember to get our free daily podcasts
the one-hour podcast on iTunes stitcher
google play or any of your favorite
podcasting apps we are there grab that
daily podcast we love it
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinking the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blinka store free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash David Pakman I've
also included the link right underneath
this video